how the hell is there never been a movie
called Valentine's Day before there was
never some Rock Hudson Doris Day vehicle
kicking around it's a shame that such a
useful title had to be wasted on trick
garbage like this today is Valentine's
Day Radio s position also movie weighs
very little time giving us a roll
credits moment I mean we're still in the
credits you think after all those years
of being on Grey's Anatomy together Eric
Dane only agreed to do this film because
his name would be ahead of Patrick
Dempsey's movie plants it's Flag
stirring Lee on the side of Team Jacob
you know they could save time in the
opening credits by just telling us the
people in Hollywood that weren't in this
cooking movie but I shut down my play
earnest from New Year's to st. Patty's
Day just so I can avoid this the most
preposterous part of this movie is the
fact that every mother there is a full
and willing participant in one of the
least interesting holidays of the year
no no no no not open until perfect
moment dude he's trying to surprise his
fiancee so why can't he you look into
the fucking box the director said let's
have your character juggle three apples
before you eat one in the scene it'll
make you look like even more of a
cheating asshole I do have something to
do I just don't know that I want to do
it Jennifer Garner used this exact same
died long before grudgingly attending
the live by night premiere Jesus Christ
does every character in this movie have
to be shown getting out of bed revenge
porn at the time in the era of
cellphones and all kinds of other
digital doohickeys there's zero chance
that no one knows what the time is
but movie after movie keeps cranking out
this convenient cliche I know it's
supposed to be a surprise that liz is a
phone sex operator isn't it more
surprising that phone sex operators
still exist even in 2010 my roommate
just at home do you want to have a
threesome if he says yes it'll take me a
minute to change this is the movie
equivalent of bad 70s sitcom also
apparently this random dog walker is
ready for group sex with a stranger at a
moment's notice
look I know Taylor Swift has this weird
fascination with the number 13 and that
she used to write in our hand during
concerts but the fact that Gary Marshall
didn't make her wash that chip off
during this movie is worth I don't know
let's go with 13 sins do you live here
in this building cuz I see you in the
lobby all the time cuz I live here
Taylor's character was originally named
distractingly
annoying girl in elevator and instead of
calling you back on your phone I decided
to come all the way down to your place
of business on the busiest day of the
year we're gonna fly up it suppose Julia
is a elementary school teacher and is no
doubt grossly underpaid but she can
afford a last-minute plane ticket to San
Francisco that's Valentine's Day you
don't think you do come to hell on pink
Celso Valentine's Day is not the throw
caution to the wind holiday everyone
knows that st. Patrick's Day hey honey
I'm just pulling into the airport
doctormick sleazy fatty juggle well
movie works overtime delay on this
juggling metaphor as sickly as possible
why you should speak English I have to a
night game there's only one fucking
flower that would start with Chris so
Michaels either the worst fuckin floor
shop worker in the history of floral
retail or he's just a blogger racist
asshole we gonna get there grandpa
you're telling me that all the events of
this movie so far have happened before
the beginning of the school day what
time is first period noon they just made
a big deal about Edison hand making all
of his Valentines but he's gonna go with
a store-bought option for his most
important gift
I might just send a dozen of those to
the best girl at my school okay I know
Reid's just trying to be nice here but
this is a terrible economic lesson to
teach this kid wait a second this
asshole wants $1,500 for a 1982 Tercel
that's literally highway robbery his
contract is up and at age 35 he's one of
the oldest quarterbacks in the league
movies so lazy about Sean's backstory
that it tags in SportsCenter to cover it
look I really like Love Actually but the
success of that movie made Hollywood
think any romantic movie could include a
cast of 100 stars and could totally work
so I guess club actually character
accidentally increases speed on a
treadmill and freaks the hell out about
a cliche today at lunch I'm gonna have
sex with my boyfriend for the first time
I know a high schools or liberal inch
who the hell tells their teacher this
information and who the hell loses their
virginity during lunch period I hate
first no deep I think it means foreplay
what you think we're gonna wait Taylor
Lautner gets John Mayer by Taylor Swift
we got to the playoffs it was all Lee
yes this sporting verbage was definitely
written by someone very familiar with
football matches and the scoring of the
balls by the backs and
Valentine's Day was a massacre in
Chicago where they shot everybody and
put a curse on the Chicago cops
this checks out I need two arrangements
something special long-stem roses for
each one of my ladies why does Harrison
have to make this so awkward one of the
arrangements could have been for his
mother or sister he doesn't have to be
this transparent you need any help
thanks guy we needed this situation to
somehow get creepier yes nothing
provides the backdrop of modern young
lust like a foreigner song from 1984
also they're going to her house to have
some afternoon delight right why the
hell didn't they ride together movie
inspires more than 50% of the current
pornhub content I realized Alex was
freaked out about Grace's mom coming
home but it's that really reason to
abandon all logic and run through the
goddamn neighborhood completely naked
and punish you Jesus Christ she's doing
this in an open cubicle why is she even
the least bit surprised that people
would be within earshot he's a man
online too asking me to cover him up in
Vaseline and bubble wrap so these guys
have her work number too how's that even
possible we learned earlier she was
filling in for Paula's receptionist now
a free agent I get the feeling that
Shaun listens to sports media just to
get the exposition of his own career
maybe check out Craigslist Sean is a 35
year old apparently very good
quarterback at the very worst he would
be an expensive backup QB on some team
Ike I need to talk to you a second Reid
was gonna tell Julia this whole time
about Harrison why did he even deliver
the flowers did you even consider
marrying me of course I did yeah for
about 11 seconds before the movie cut to
one of its other 78 plot threats the
whole stopping the girl at the airport
from making a big mistake usually
happens at the end of the movie but here
we've still got an hour to go I
surprised my husband once now he's my
ex-husband surprise shadowing Reid
drives down the completely empty access
road to LAX despite it being right at
rush hour take it easy yeah the place I
mean wouldn't an e-ticket get Reid into
all the gates of the airport I know Reid
is anxious to get to Julia but he's
literally risking federal imprisonment
for this bull did he say that it was
asked why he didn't have to I could tell
actually he explicitly told greed that
he was sending one arrangement to his
girlfriend and one to his wife but I
guess Reid doesn't feel the need to
specify I don't want this to
happy to you I'm sorry about Morley I'm
going to see my boyfriend me why hasn't
Julia even entertaining the notion that
Harrison is married like couldn't she at
least call him and ask if this is for
real
sir your shoes are still at security
this TSA agent let this long
conversation play out before politely
informing Greene that they have his
shoes this is the least believable part
of this movie in a movie with a lot of
stars it's odd that the least
interesting and most forgettable
storyline is the one with arguably the
two biggest stars even in 2010 I said
what the heck is wrong with you I'm in
love so am i but I can move my feet this
fucking ref takes the time to chastise
Edison but completely ignores Franklin
putting his shirt over his head while
and go also in case your same person
that's not keeping count Luffy has three
shots of Franklin pulling his shirt up
over his head for no goddamn reason is
the game over
they just started less than two minutes
ago this is some weirdly where whoever
scores first wins
so I'm Calvin more channel 13 Happy
Valentines
did they have Calvin out on the street
all day doing this Valentine's Day polls
she's local man this dude discount Adam
Sandler so hard that I combed through
the IMDB credits and was positive it was
wrong Sean Jackson is calling press
conferences to be my exclusive if Sean
called the press conference which would
be open to the public how that would
that be an exclusive ah forget art this
movie doesn't need logic it just throws
characters together and an unfunny
pastiche in hopes to dazzle you with
star power guesswork I hear ya blast
killed in soul quest was to convince
Keira to set up an interview with Sean
but he just pieces out after her
meltdown sure it was a distraction but
seriously he completely forgot all about
why he was here so Greg just randomly
decided to go to some high school to get
romantic footage isn't that illegal can
someone remind me why the hell I care
about any of these fucking characters
I'm supposed to get our Prius to be
dating for like two weeks then why are
you so goddamn concerned about
Valentine's Day so how did you guys meet
there is zero chance any news channel
would spend this amount of time on this
story why is this movie over two hours
you may ask well this scene screams fuck
you that's why Alex and I were supposed
to have sex today Jesus Christ does
Greece need to tell everyone about this
did she inform the soccer Ref doing a
break in the game hearing myself say it
out loud it all sounds really stupid
Emma Roberts first reaction to reading
the script somehow made it into the
final cut of the film
Edison is able to evade grace for the
entire journey despite grace pursuing
him immediately
in her car dr. copelan married they just
celebrated their 15th anniversary these
drop garden early seating luckily for
Julia and the movie these two nurses
just happened to know every detail about
Harrison's life care I'm still here I'm
in LA julia was boarding the plane to
San Francisco and blatantly disregarded
Reed's warning so how the hell did she
stay in LA I'll just say the thing I
came here to say I'm gay
wow what a stunning revelation from a
character that we've seen for maybe 30
seconds of screen time she's still
looking for that little asshole he only
had like a 50-yard head start Edgar yeah
but grace was literally just at their
house and could have easily run inside
to tell the medicine took off good
evening okay even if Julia didn't get on
her flight it was booked for 5:30 p.m.
so she had to leave LAX drive all the
way to the hospital find out the truth
about Harrison and learned that his
dinner is an early seating then go all
the way home change clothes set up the
deal with the restaurant manager and
pose as a waitress also the Sun sets
around 5:30 p.m. in LA in February so
why is it so goddamn sunny right now
God's movie is actively abusing my
intelligence charge these two my friend
over there yeah that's what I figured so
I put in some extra lobster tails and
the cheesecake sure Harrison is a
douchebag but this is essentially
outright theft
we've seen that Liz schedules these
appointments well in advance so why
don't you book a time during her date
with venom still got a few hours left
make something happen we just got
engaged and dumped over the last 12
hours or so but we'll immediately begin
a relationship with his best friend
because Valentine's Day is not already a
month how is this day not over yet this
has been a long-ass day in the history
of film set during one day
luckily for Reed's Valentine boner the
Rodriguez family gathers within the
frame of this easily viewable window
thank you
he's a lucky man did she tell limitless
that she's going to see her son or did
she avoid that topic during the entirety
of the 14-hour flight
talk to you next time oh god yeah it's
shocking that anyone would be able to
hear this phone sex that's happening on
a public looking bench I have a hundred
K student loan I have absolutely no idea
how I'm gonna pay off if you know of a
job that will pay a poetry major more
than $40 an hour with her clothes on I'm
all ears maybe Jason shouldn't leave Liz
because she's a phone sex operator but
he should consider the fact that she
took out a hundred thousand dollar loan
to major in poetry and then leave her
you are we taking
how would Edison know where Julia is and
for all Reed knows she's in fucking San
Francisco also read to our knowledge has
never opened this box what if there's a
dildo in there I know Julia got the food
from the other restaurant to screw
Harrison but she's meeting Kara at a
fucking restaurant so bringing this is a
super dick move ah finally all that
electric training put to good use
Julia's sure gets a lot of free rein in
LA restaurants the grass is on top of
the people so what the hell are they
supposed to do wait these Rando
characters that show up at the end of
the party aren't super famous people for
Kate Hudson and Jennifer Lopez really
not available
I'm his florists instead of informing
Edison's caregivers about his
whereabouts Reid chucked him in the van
and took him to a restaurant when you
love someone you love all of them that's
the job I know that no when did Edgar
have this realization Estelle just told
him about the affair this afternoon and
he's just been sitting out here drinking
whiskey with Foreman for about an hour
or so and what kind of flimsy ass
apology is this first ell it's not even
really an apology
sure your grace knows that Edison's here
but considering they're out of the
movies his grandparents could apparently
give a rat's ass Kara who's a f--king
professional sports publicist doesn't
know how to give a fist bump at least
this movie didn't have an impromptu
dancing scene where everyone knows the
choreography perfectly god damn it we
can still make out Alex once again
proves that the power of boners is
greater than the power of delivering a
hot tikka masala to hungry customers
also glad to see the whole Alex and
grace storyline wrapped up now we just
have 23 more to go before the end of
this movie magic swing set turns the
wine from red to white and seconds flat
listen I know Shawn's had a long day but
there's no excuse for lighting this many
candles
falling asleep Sean Jackson has popped
the lock on the closet and come out what
does this mean for Sean Jackson will
there be more house music played in the
locker room even while praising Sean's
courage movie has to get in a cheap-ass
gay joke I stand behind you Sean
metaphorically awesome thanks for
closing it sounds strong Jamie I just
spent all night in a cemetery actually
you've only made it through half of a
movie before bailing so this is not a
good argument to be made for your level
of commitment I'm about to kiss my best
friend yeah I'm with the punk guy on
this one even by movie standards this
relationship is moving at lightning
speed somehow the movie found a second
partner for Ashton Kutcher with less
on-screen chemistry than Jessica Alba
movie has such an oculist surprise twist
that zero viewers are shocked when they
haven't we got to sit through them
instead of trimming the 30 minutes this
movie needs so desperately trimmed off
we're passing the famous Rodeo Drive you
ever shopped here I think once actually
a big mistake got a figure after this
scene Julia Roberts told Gary Marshall
that her pretty woman debt was all paid
up after doing this crap
[Music]
Valentine's Day Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day I know what day it is
love stinks not open until perfect
moment know what's in the bog I need you
first take it out of terminal G what are
you the boyfriend here for a quickie can
I just go up why I get it why waste time
making small talk with door man when I
was a kid I snuck into my mother's
bedroom well she was laying there naked
Dean cheap and drinking all night b'gok
if he says yes it'll take me a minute to
change I'd buy that amazing grace
come sit on my face oh I miss high
school that's what I love about these
high school girls man I get older they
stay the same age
[Music]